Howdy, Charles.
>> Howdy, Howdy.
>> Sure, why not. How's it going?
>> How do? It's, doing quite well. Thank you for asking.
>> Sure.
>> How's it going on your end of the world?
>> I'm feeling okay, let's say. Though I'm a little concerned because
last time we, we were talking and you said you had a question.
And I promised that I would get into it. And it's, it's complicated,
but it's really interesting. So let's,
let's remind ourselves what the question was.
So, we're talking about bounding the number of samples that
we need to learn. A classifier or a concept in
some given hypothesis base, h. and we ended up driving
a formula that looks like this. So, the formula tells us
that we're okay, as long as the number of samples
is at least as large as 1 over the air parameter,
epsilon ; times the quantity log of the number of
hypotheses. Plus the log of 1 over the failure parameter. And,
and so if the We want to make sure that we succeed with very
low failure probabilities. Delta's very small and
that means we need more samples and if
we want to make sure that this error is really small, that also makes
this quantity big, which means we need
more samples. Right, so do you remember this?
>> I do remember this.
>> Alright and what was your concern?
>> Well my concern was that the number of depended
on the size of the hypothesis space. And I was
wondering what happen if you have a
really, really large hypothesis space. Like for
example, one of infinite size or infinite
cardinality I suppose is the right term.
>> Alright well let's do a quiz.